let's start don't mean to mock your
foolish okay we're gonna start it off
against the book in because the Vulcan
has been Suba it'll help you learn you
Kimmy which is more difficult than body
as you can fake choreography in the body
are you can it's very difficult to fake
choreography in weapons you have to know
how to absorb and neutralize through
absorption okay and that Suba will give
you a little extra measure of safety and
I'm going to tell you if you depend on
that super to save your hat it doesn't
work okay just a little bit extra so
maybe instead of breaking three
metacarpals only to play okay all right
so we're gonna begin very static he
should be around enough where he does
Tsuyoshi shuffle step it you can hit me
with the Vulcan and showman see okay so
that's how far we should be and as I do
my technique then a fiber to newest key
my Steve should not touch in here but
she
to penetrate the target pool see that so
you have to learn where this is okay so
we're gonna help you learn it by being
very embryonic at first all right here's
the riches of ritual the routine he is
in Sagan in diamonds Sega okay or this
kind of garden positioning so I'm not
going to but I'm here neutral I am going
to begin the ritual by giving the
opening it's by hey so the first move
starts from here whoa second move he did
sukiyaki show Mickey whoa and he wants
to reach out in training training I want
you to reach out further than you might
want to because I want your head out of
the way we'll do it again steps one into
a little close
and watch what I do to my cart
individual I actually take my keys over
it bring my head forward slightly so
here I am
[Music]
my weight goes down as I do that so I'm
ready to move hide the weight shift in
the target baby
he will email up exhale
look at him now so he wants his hands
parallel to the shoulders you see that
when you're practicing I don't want you
touching people on the head give
yourself that kind of inch they're two
inches but that is way too far away okay
all right let's do steps one and two
go high let's move here so again if I'm
too short and my Tsuyoshi can't reach
the target it doesn't matter
the range is dictated by I gotta be safe
before I know it would I go it I might
have to shuffle in take it make sure I'm
in range
it doesn't matter I might have to step
in for the ritual you're not going to be
in it come on or you're over like this
you take the same neutral quick stance
and you move forward boom so if my back
heel is up not down and my feet are
under my hips here don't bring a sword
but understand how quick this is so he
gives you up ooh I'm going to hit gives
you opening it's going to close again
okay then start timing your movement go
not here move when he moves when this
has starts to drop
okay let's go
okay next step three he goes for this
every rocket level I now wait till he's
there I will move off towards the zone
is sanctuary at four o'clock hey my foot
and my attention is pointed and he
Center from that angle and not come here
and being a parallel and I'm starting a
rotational geometry so again embryonic
Li we all wait both goes we saw
when I move my body will rotate into
that flight you're gonna want to do this
to side shuttles you see that difference
routed it's about a quarter turn tops
maybe less with that movement you're
going to see that my right hip is gonna
come slightly forward in with my right
hip coming forward my right hand can get
pushed up at this point he will make
contact with my job it doesn't have to
be one each me son sheep each me
okay let's go okay here's where we start
losing people even though we're going
everyone this not only what you do but
how you do it this is important in life
okay so he comes in when I rotate my
hips if I'm now is looking over here
he's more flanking me than I am him do
you copy that I was told my foot should
be pointing towards him and his spine my
sentence and this one you see that if I
bring my foot over here I can do that
but that's an awkward stance isn't it so
probably my Center is over here that's
he's flanking me so when I move it's
here now some of you go although center
facing and then you strengthen that rear
foot out you bring this hip forward you
see that now you don't have on me you're
a full-width can you see that are you
doing this then rest - you are over here
so go slow because it's all stops he
stopped I just now have to do my part
hey that's here you
I
alright alright now I'm gonna give you
some reference points to make sure you
know you're in the right place so I gave
you two already put is that his spine
centers at the spine okay
next reference point look where my Joe
is in relation to his Suba it's about
four to six inches when you do this
wrong look where it is look how long
that is okay when you do the other
shuffle where you just go out to the
side
you are four to six inches but your job
is beardy across his sore line watch
where mine is eat me boom you see how
much joy I have okay
[Applause]
I also want you to watch what I'm doing
with my hands so the right hand the
right hand is going to curl all the way
over don't hold it here and the straight
wrist curl it all the way over the left
hand is in this view shape and don't
need to grab it tight cause tension here
okay let's get there okay so it's what I
do how I do it right and there's going
to be a cap to I can't go too little I
can't do it too full too far over here
please
okay so oh you go wrong boom I'm out
here you guys are not like that is your
clothes okay what I'm going to do with
this is Umbreon ugly I'm going to go
around this joke and he's bokun attack
the top of the supe and hit his wrist
with the striking portion of my jib
so take off that first inch and then you
got that next three inches you see this
so that's too far not far my
we're gonna go slow yeah so how far you
go out I'm looking at his hands I'm
gonna leave it Joe there it is now not a
weapon it is a vector and I'm really
used for training I'm going to keep
contact as I go around his weapon to the
other side round in the other side see
how I'm doing that and I'll be here on
his tuba and I start to push down pull
my head and he will practice absorbing
with his Center right now
Ariana Klee it looks like I'm locking
I'm nothing you don't block in Aikido
this is just perform for learning I go
it around and you see down top the
weapon laughs underneath my rear
posterior chain application on my big
foot the weapon is pointed at is fine
you see that
[Music]
the right hand is the power and that's
what's under your center line you weight
line
notice how I roll the top the front hand
over the top at the end the joke ends
parallel to the ground - let's try
River and he's not a he's not a weapon
now he is a factor so I don't want to
move his weapon is it correct mechanics
on the show I'm going around it you see
it hasn't moved
do you see that it hasn't moved and I
want to straight down oh that
displacement that you're seen is not
from me doing an angle of deflection
it is a displace the displacement to why
those objects cannot occupy the same
space at the same time it'll move do you
understand don't try to move it just to
your power
so your goal is go around it he has to
leave it there right if you don't leave
it there and I'm going around it I'm
making contact with it you see there's
contact with it you see and I get on the
other side of it boom straight down yeah
okay I'll slowly blow at this key and he
will practice and secondly Kimmy
it's exactly the same don't get dead
okay we're gonna go slow my targets
gonna be the rib cage that I clear and
he will just go into the back bring fall
not a million miles ahead don't practice
that slowly you're not gonna be a
million miles ahead ride in perfect
harmony with the young energy of the
joke okay so we do it add back to our
sequence each go oh and then we draw the
joke stay there first
my ski is gonna go past the target you
see that do not count to hear like
you're tagging sharks hands
[Applause]
and he goes with that
Hey